c'est tout le monde s'amuse on est
content de se retrouver
et au bout d'un moment
découvrez que maylis
on la retrouve pas au réal à 10 par mois
elle est plus là elle est plus là au
début où vous dites bon elle a dû aller
jouer bas au début on la cherche pas ce
que tu vois là c'est aller quelque part
elle joue
où elle est allée se reposer ou
donc on cherche qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les heures qui ont suivi les
minutes les heures
c'est un cauchemar cauchemar c'est un
cauchemar on cherche on la trouve pas
et après ça s'enchaîne la gendarmerie
les militaires l'hélicoptère
les enquêteurs la criminelle enfin
c'est comme dans un film c'est sa
surface et à quel moment aucun moment
même vous qui étiez au mariage vous êtes
dit
se passe quelque chose de grave
assez rapidement quand même assez
rapidement vraiment vous êtes dit c'est
bizarre qu'on l'a pas du tout ça c'est
bizarre c'est pas dans ses habitudes et
puis elle connaissait pas l'endroit
musée nuit c'était à 3 heures du matin
elle connaissait pas beaucoup de monde
parce que l les voyez pas souvent donc
ce n'était pas normal qu'on ne trouve
pas
dans les jours qui ont suivi la
disparition de ben ali faisait encore de
l'espoir où
très vite vous étiez très inquiète avec
votre famille vous êtes dit gardait
l'espoir mais au fond nous ah oui on
savait qu'il y avait peu de choses pas
les heures sont comptées 1
c'est vrai que même quand vous on se
repose quand on voit les images on a
tous vu les images du lieu du mariage on
se met à votre place on se dit c'est
c'est vraiment un cauchemar c'est un
cauchemar forcément culpabiliser
on aurait dû surveiller on aurait dû oui
on se dit qu'on aurait dû rester plus
avec elle en sticker n'aurait pas dû
aller s'amuser
qu'on n'aurait pas dû venir au mariage
mm on a pressé mais voilà quoi peut pas
prévoir a bien sûr à partir du 31 août
2010 est normal le landais et placé en
garde à vue
ce jour là vous êtes dit ça y est on
sait que c'est là on a là on a la clé de
l'énigme ouais
assez vous l'aviez vu vous au mariage
aperçue à bercy voilà rien de
way deal et ela a cessé pour le
connaissez pas donc il n'y avait pas du
tout parlé à la soirée ils ont ce qu
après c'est vrai que l'on doit se dire
on va essayer de se souvenir est ce
qu'on l'a vue est-ce qu'il était seul
est qui et qui le seul moment où moi je
vais parler c'est avec ma soeur quand on
cherche et maëlys alors m comment les
enquêteurs sont mis sur la piste de
nordahl le landais forcément ils ont
regardé les vidéos du mariage ils sont
dix il ya eu toute une série de toute
une série de failles et d'aborder des
témoignages des invités au mariage qui
on est et on va dire suspicieux à
l'égard de nordahl hollandais des
témoignages également très vite
témoignages de membres de la famille de
miley et notamment de la maman de miley
ce qui très rapidement va a indiqué aux
enquêteurs que nordey le landais avaient
créé une proximité toute particulière
est pour le moins intrigante vis-à-vis
de la de la petite maelys vous avez
effectivement c'est cette image où
effectivement nordahl hollandais va
montrer ça je pense que c'est connu
maintenant de nombreux français montré
des images de ces chiens sur son
téléphone portable il va crier en fait
une proximité avec avec la petite maëlys
et puis ensuite au fil du travail des
enquêteurs eh bien les éléments
concordants vont se diriger vers nordahl
landais est finalement très vite
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient quoi au mariage
ont été invités par kim noorda le
landais alors ça c'est ça fait partie
des éléments qu'on va dont on va
discuter dont on va débattre devant
devant la cour d'assises la question
qu'on va qu'on va se poser c'est de
savoir s'il a été invité ou non s'il
s'est invitée à ce mariage c'est
toujours pas ça si on a on a des
éléments au dossier qui tendent plutôt à
caractériser le fait qu'effectivement
nordahl hollandais s'est bel et bien
inviter à ceux à ce mariage qui n'était
pas spécialement le bienvenu
c'est incroyable donc
ensuite très vite des preuves existent
contre lui lesquels très vite les
premières preuves de multiples éléments
concordants alors on a d'ores et déjà
très rapidement dans les premiers temps
des investigations une trace adn qui
être retrouvées sur le tableau de bord
traces adn donc de la petite maelys qui
va être retrouvée sur le tableau de bord
d'une audi de l'audi a3 du du mis en
examen et puis ensuite on va avoir
d'autres éléments notamment une scène
qui est particulièrement troublante ces
lavages récurage du véhicule par nordahl
le landais quelques heures après la
disparition de la petite maëlys et
quelques minutes à peine après qu'il ait
été entendu par les enquêteurs comme
tous les invités du mariage parce que
après après telles fêtes où les invités
du mariage ont été ont été entendues
dans le cadre d'une audition libre par
les services de la gendarmerie après son
audition d'un enquêteur il ils disent
tout de suite on a on est on est sur la
bonne personne et sur le ca je peux pas
vous dire parce que ça c'est du ressenti
oui ce n'est pas le ressenti des
enquêteurs dans le cadre du dans le
cadre du dossier mais très vite
effectivement on va avoir des éléments
objectivement accablant à l'égard de cet
individu
derrière c'est finalement février 2018
que le corps de maylis va être retrouvée
sur les indications d'ailleurs de dalles
le landais j'imagine pour la famille
ça doit être un moment terrible c'est le
coup de grâce c'est ça tu es le coup de
grâce on se dit que vous la reverra plus
c'est fini
tant qu'on l'avait pas retrouvé on avait
petit espoir bien sûr que c'est possible
mais là ce jour là c'était
notre vie qui s'écoule
la vie de toute la famille c'était cool
et jour la
demande depuis vous ne vivez plus jamais
comme avant
on s'est plus tard et
ça nous a changé ça a bouleversé nos
vies nos couples nos métiers
c'est tout un tas de choses derrière
tout ça quoi